[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled development and
Manufacturing strategy for DNA based
drug vaccine candidates this webinar is
part of the fifth annual event in the
bioprocessing virtual event series I'm
Shelley muok of labroots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labroots and sponsored by genscript for
more information about genscript go to
[Music]
find the live chat located at the left
of your screen you can also participate
by submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click submit we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the
presentation you will also notice that
the speaker has provided a survey
located to the right of the abstract
this survey will be available during
both the live session and the on demand
period are displayed
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the top of your screen
within the navigation bar or from the
lobby credits I now present today's
speaker Dr Mark way senior director of
plasmid and virus process development
and Manufacturing Department gen script
probo and Dr we will be assisted by
hu for a complete biography on our spe
speakers please visit the presenter tab
from the menu at the left of your screen
Dr way you may now begin your
presentation hello everyone so today
we're going to present for development
and Manufacturing strategy for pdna
based drug vaccine candidates so before
we start I would like to introduce
introduce our company so we are probo a
global cdmo company neutured by
genescript uh our Manufacturing
foodprints and sales fruit pring expands
in China Korea Japan EU and US
market we currently have over 300 plus
en virro VOR project undergoing a
different stage from CMC to commercial
manufacturing and as a global company we
have formed partnership with numerous
leading organization across the world
our plasmid has been utilized by over
160 big farmers and top biotech
companies
worldwide so first I would like like to
introduce some of the pdna based vaccine
drug marketing and
trending so the Outlook of the DNA
vaccine Market appears very promising
currently there are no available
candidates for human use and only three
options exist for animal use this leaves
significant room for the development of
new
products as of
2022 more than 57% of the DNA vaccine
projects remain in preclinical stage
while the remaining 43% are undergoing
clinical trials that necessitate the use
of GMP plus M
manufacturing of DNA vaccine projects
nearly 20% of those are focused on
covid-19 which of course has been the
major topic of the discussion in the
recent
years so plasmid are optimal importancy
in the development of Advanced
Therapeutics it serves as a key raw
material in in the manufacturing of lvv
or aav for cell and gen therapy drugs
well it also serves as a pdna vaccine
drug product and today that's what we
are going to focus
on so for the plasmid development and
Manufacturing strategy is what we're
going to discuss
next so what is plasmid so plasmid is a
small circular DNA molecules in the
cytoplasm of the cells that can rep
repli at and transfer
autonomously and often carries a gene
information that is beneficial for the
survival of the health cell so in the N
nature the plasma exhibits virus shapes
under this Electro microscope so over
here we can see different shapes that
Plasma in the nature presents however
during our
production our goal is to obtain the
superco plasmid as our final
product as for the DNA
vaccine the mechanism is showed in this
picture it use a genetic material from a
path engine to stimulate an immune
response it contains a plasmid that has
the inserted Gene once the plasmid has
completed the transcription inside the
body it will generate mRNA which will
further Express antigen inside the
body so to carry out this genetic
material we can use a DNA plasmid a
microser DNA or Dodge bone a Dodge bone
is a DNA structure also known as DB DNA
that is modified DNA molecule typically
using in the preparation of a gapy or a
DNA vaccine in this case a name D derly
from its shape which reassemble a dog
bone so the FDA has two important
approval stage for drug development the
first being the indd investigational new
drug stage evaluates all drugs that are
ready for clinical trial FES for the
laboratory use and next is the new drug
application stage which evaluates all
animal and human data to approve drugs
for treatment of
disease so over here for the D pdna drug
development the road map typically
started with a basical research followed
by a CMC chemistry manufacturing
controls and non-clinical
testings after that the indd submission
is made and three phase of study is
conducted
including phase one for safety
evaluation phase two for dose efficiency
assessment and phase three for efficient
comparison to the current
therapy the development of plid drug
involves several key stages including
cell line development process
development formulation development
analytical method development and
validation and scale up and GMP
manufacturing so first a high tighter
stable sale line is selected and a
master sale bank is then established
then process development stage will
begin with a small scale process to
identify to identify critical process
parameters and quality attributes a
formulation development then is made for
plasmid which is pretty typical for a
straightforward process due to the
stability of the material but do need
additional investigation for this is due
to to the plasmus was made into final
drug substance as a vaccine
itself analytical meth development and
validation is crucial to control batch
release of the final product which
finally after the process has been
optimized and validated it can be scaled
up for pilot scales drug product
production and then GMP manufacturing
followed by stability
studies in order to provide a detailed
account of production process we'll
begin by outlining those
steps the initial and crucial step
involves the selection of suitable
bacteria strin for the cell banking
production as the function of the
different strains can vary during the
cell culture
stage this will illustrate a family map
of those different distinct
strains in the B process
selections understanding those virus
genome types of eoli and their associate
phenotypes can Aid in identifying an
ideal strength ultimately this will lead
to a significant Improvement in plasma
manufacturing process Gene Knockin and
knockout method can be employed to
modify those strengths to meet specific
process requirements during our
development
stage so a proper sourcing of the host
string and template plasmid is vidto to
Kickstart the pdna CMC study at probo we
ensure a clear history of the string
used for plasmid manufacturing and
guarantee that these strings are
licensed for commercial use with sub
licensed authority to prevent any
roadblocks during the late GMP
manufacturing process additionally we
also offer support throughout the bla
and da process and future
commercialization efforts for the sales
we provide the original records for
Strings and development records we also
provide the Gen synthetic records for
the plasmic
constructions so over here we like to
show some of the case studies that we
have this case studies demonstrate the
importance of a string screening and
selection a string with a good passage
stability for sale banking is critical
so a por passage stability string was
found to exhibit an extra band at Ace
passage and this could because of the
same origin conflict the the extra band
become more even pronounced at the
temp's passage this extra band material
will be difficult to remove during the
downstream
processing on the other hand the string
B over here shows no extra band even at
a tense passage furthermore those second
string exhibits a great stability with a
high plasma yield and retention rate
make it more suitable for a large scale
production as no plasmid would be lost
during the scaling up process using this
good
string so here we demonstrate a process
overview for our plasma manufacturing
process this including upstream and
downstream processing so we start with
the
fermentation then we collect the cell
for cell harvesting we lice our celles
and through clarification process we
further down to concentrating of our
material and moving on to Downstream
processing so we first do geo filtration
which removes our
RNA then move on to Affinity columns
which capture the super coiled DNA and
move on to an aex process for polishing
the
material further down we do an UF DF
again to exchange out the buffer for our
formulation during the
process so our all in-house strain
offers a full traceability and sub
license authorization and our suspension
C is free of animal origin and
antibiotics our high density formation
process is in Upstream has a yield up to
one gram per
liter this resulting in a costeffective
product with a high
yield additionally our Downstream
process bring a recovery between 20 to
60% depending on the product
specification so this is a pass for indd
and B CMC study we started with a
prelimin preliminary
evaluation then follow up with the
process development and a small batch
production to that we can lock down the
critical process parameters and move on
to process evaluation report and the
settle on the process
specifications an indd badge production
then is completed it followed by a
process characterization and validation
studies finally the boa will be
committed as
is so asset development is a crucial
component of our process development for
plasma
manufacturing as it forms a key part of
our risk-based analyze control strategy
through this strategy we aim to ensure
the robustness of our manufacturing
process with the right level of process
control to mitigate risk and maintain
the quality of our process from raw
material throughout to final
product
so we also took a very Sy systemic
approach with the optimization process
during the fermentation stage so by
evaluation of all of those key factors
of each project we determine the perfect
condition for each process in order to
increase efficiency and improve product
quality
those key factors could be subtrate
which is De feed to the cells pressures
stir speed air flow viscosity
and osmotic pressures here's a picture
of our Upstream manufacturing Process
Equipment that we use on site in
probo so experimental design rely on
fundamental principle of fermentation
this include energy energy utilization
metabolism and information transf
which chose fermentation process align
with the plasmus sequence and the
bacteria growth trade which enable us to
achieve a high yield and improved
quality after optimization our
fermentation yield can reach up to 1.5
gr per
liter so we would like to present a case
study outlining the optimalization of
our option
process spe specifically we made
adjustment to the pH level components
and concentration result in medium
optimization of this process and the
outcome of this modification exceeded
our expectation with the yield increased
by almost threefolds and surpassing the
one gram per liter Mark at the 32-hour
Mark additionally we our growth of our
product is now more consistent and
stable after optimization has been
happened so regarding the the downstream
platform of our plasmid the process we
utilize is highly effective at
eliminating the impurities and
contaminations those including hcp hcdna
and
ototoxin this results in a high
concentration of drug substance for
production during our most successful
batch demonstrated a purity of over 99%
of super
coiled plasmid and less than 0.1 for
scdna
and with the level of htcp falling below
quantification
limit our endotoxin content is measur
less than one EU per milligram at our
best
performance and here we're pleased to
present another case study highlighting
the successful optimization of our
client upstream and downstream
process in the Upstream process we made
modification to the culture condition
and supplement strategy
this results in an impressive 2.6 fold
increase in optical density and 4.8 fold
increase in
yield similarly during the downstream
process we were able to improve our
ultra filtration and D filtration
process recover rate from 73% to 90%
while also reducing the whol cell DNA
content from
0.3% to
0.1%
so here's another case study on
stability of a pilot scales production
once we have established the process
parameters we conduct three consecutive
runs with a pilot
scale those data presented over here
indicated a very high re liability of
our manufacturing process the OD CV is
less than or equal to
5.1% and the yield CV is less or equal
to 11% for the fermentation process this
demonstrate a very very stable
production capacity on the later stage
process so once all the upstream and
downstream process has been concluded we
move on to the formulation process of
our drug product process the DP
formulation development process involves
three major stages the first stage the
preformulation consists of Designing of
the formul conduct compatibility study
and predict the stability in the Second
Stage Formula velopment we screen and
select appropriate packaging material
and complete stress and stability test
to assure our product can be stable
during a harsh condition in the
selective formula once all parameter has
been optimized we scale up the
production and complete verification and
process proceeding to the manufacturing
for GMP
failing and with the new needle free
tech knowledge delivering the method of
the
plasmid is very easy and
effective so moving on is to our quality
system so quality is an essential Factor
throughout the entire production process
starting from the vector design and
continually through the release of the
raw material in process control and
product release
specifications it is throughout the
whole Manufacturing body is the
key the a range of test is performed on
the releasing of the raw
materials those are conducted to ensure
the production of a high quality drug
product from the beginning this includes
characterization of a cell bank and
stability test characterization of the
strin bank and a stability test release
of all the ra materials including
release of the O excipients and the
packaging materials as well
to ensure the quality of the plasmid a
bunch of testing has also performed in
four different categories including
physical and chemistry property
characterization Purity and
safety those those different method is
available in the house for us to verify
the product quality to ensure the
plasmid is safe and
stable so in addition to all those
various test on plasmid our mtic
qualification is also carried out during
determination of the acceptance criteria
for the
asset once this analytical method are
qualified those product material then
will need to pass all those criterias so
it can be
released to the manufacturing
team here's in a case study for overall
seeing indicates a high quality PLM
product
first we can see the hplc analyze of the
plasmid indicate that there's over 80%
of the content which in form of super
coiled
plasmid and over here the Restriction
digestion analy matches the anticipated
pattern as well as the plasma sequence
analyze also corresponding to the
predicted DNA sequence shows a high
quality of the plasma
product so we also utilize three
distinct in-house method to access the
plasmid Purity this is tailored to
specific need of each stage process for
example aggr G electris is fast
technolog to use during the sale banking
stage this ensures a fast turnaround
time and during the process development
stage an aex hlc is utilized to provide
a more throughout analyze of the plasma
Purity data and finally in the final
project stage the super code percentage
is typically accessed using a capillary
electr process method to obtain a high
resolution data on the Purity
profile so we also possess a Cutting
Edge sequencing technology on house
which allows us to improve detection of
certain genetic features for example
with a traditional Sanger sequencing
detecting
the inverted terminal repeats can be
very challenging however our ITR
sequence technology inhouse can accurate
reads through itrs providing a cling
Peak that enhance our Vector stability
and
safety furthermore we have recently
appro our polya sequencing capacity
which enable us to read polya up to 140
Pairs and provide more comprehensive and
detailed information about transcrypt
Toms
further on the cost of the manufacturing
process could be pretty high but
developing a coste effective and
sustainable manufacturing process
requires careful consideration before
launching the
product to this end we follow a certain
approach every single time when we
designing a new process making sure the
capacity flexibility scalability cost
quality and reg Regulatory and speed in
order to deliver a robust process to
drive down the cost of good sold of a
plasmid so through a systematic analyze
of a manufacturing cost model and
available Production Technologies it is
possible for us to identify options that
can deliver the required level of
productivity for a large scale plasma
production while still meeting batch
cost cost constraints and aligning with
the reimbursement strategy by doing so
it is possible to reduce the cost of
goods sold which is typically pretty
high for a large scale plasma
production the plus mid CDM platform for
Jin script proo will be shown
next at probo we have over 2.5 acre
manufacturing facility which is ready
currently and 5 acre in constructions
right now for plasmid manufacturing
capacity including CMC cgmp Pro and GMP
capacities this can be utilized for cell
and gen therapy process development mRNA
DNA Therapeutics and vaccines as well as
the crisper Gene editing
techniques we are also currently
constructing a new stage of a state of
art facility that is scheduling to be
commissioned in the second half of
2024 this new building will provide a
GMP operation capacity of approximately
two
acres this facilities will be also
equipped with the latest technology
including flx FL Tre and it will offer a
range of service for an upstream self
culture to automatic fi finish
process and import L this facility will
comply with the current good
manufacturing practice regulations
provide GMP capacity in
us so finally I would like to
demonstrate our excellent track record
so Jin scrip
probo has
an impressive track record over 20
Global approached investigational new
drug projects and more than 60 ongoing
indd projects we have also completed
over 300 good manufacturing practice
batches for a clinical phase covering a
world range of applications throughout
Cale therapy gene therapy and
vaccines as a technically strong vendor
we offer a range of Advantage including
a ready to use lenty helper plasmid for
a third generation lvv packaging for
celles
therapy and we also provide a readyto
use aav plasmid
for AV packaging for Gen
therapy we also have extensive
experience with plasmid for mRNA with a
poly a tail lens ranging from 70 to 150
base pairs across more than 15
projects in addition we utilize Cutting
Edge technology fill for LC DNA with
three project currently
underway we offers very high
concentration DNA vaccine for the
effective
applications so on the right over here
we're proud to present those highlights
for our indd approved project which
listed right
here that will be concluding for the
presentation today and thank you all
very much for your time and we're
anticipating any question and happy to
help thank
you
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar assisted by
Hawaii Zoo if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen so let's get
started uh so the first question that we
have today is what advantages does a DNA
vaccine offer compared to to other
vaccine types such as mRNA
vaccines oh thanks for the question so
DNA vaccine itself has several advantage
against MRN and first of all it's very
stable so the DNA vaccine are more
stable than mRNA vaccines as they are
stored at normal refrigerator
temperature without losing their
effectiveness and further on the
manufacturing of the DNA vaccine is also
easier and cheaper compared to m RNA
vaccines um furthermore I I believe DNA
vaccine is introducing a longer and
stronger lasting period compared to Mar
vacine uh corresponding to the long
immune response inside body and triggers
the tale arms as well when they do and
additionally DNA vaccine also provides a
more safe condition compared to the Mr
mRNA vaccines on the other hand okay oh
that's very very helpful thank you so
much um the next question that I see is
what is the typical turnaround time for
an indd
project so for that question the indd
project turnaround time is based totally
based on the project need so usually um
without any major modifications the
regular turnaround time should be around
eight weeks to 10
weeks okay very helpful uh next question
is do you provide any additional
services to assist with indd uh
filings uh that's of course uh at Jin
proo we provide endtoend service for
autop plasmid including DNA vaccine
services and sales therapy and gene
therapy so typically we will provide uh
regulatory Affair consultings including
any service needed if or documentation
preparation or response to fdaas and
additional to some clinical trial
management
also we provide in-house toxicology
testing PK studies on the side if
required and further on if the client is
considered moving on forward to a
GMP uh graded manufacturing Pro uh
process we are kindly to provide the
whole strategy and service later on and
also very importantly we provide a
quality control and quality assurance
services to ensure the filing of the IND
is
successful oh wonderful okay well it
looks like we have time for one more
question today and our last question
today is um whom should we contact if
we're interested in discussing our
project it's a good one to end
on oh thanks for the question so first
of all the easiest way is definitely to
log in on to jinr bio.com that have all
our service and informations listed on
the internet website and going through
details for whatever service you needed
it then find the contact information
later on to provide um whatever
information to our email or phone calls
so you can easily reach out to us and
our business development team will
respond to you in the first saying they
see
it perfect oh gosh well thank you again
ha for your assistance today and do you
have any final comments for the audience
or
thoughts um I I think I'm good good okay
wonderful uh thank you again ha for your
help today and thank you to Dr wayy for
your time and your important research as
well before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions I'd also
like to thank our sponsors Jens script
for sponsoring today's webinar uh
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on demand for two years and until April
5th 2025 Labs will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's Live Events until next time
goodbye thank you very much appreciate
it thank you
yeah